when hpo first started its programming
you know now they put like the kids
movies during the day and they save the
adult fare for night you know Jay and I
would wake up 830 a.m. on a saturday
morning turn on the TV there's Sophie's
Choice all right we'll watch this we're
gonna roll right into Kramer vs Kramer
okay ordinary people great try that one
out just fruit loops and hard-hitting
relationship dramas with divorce and
yeah our friends were watching Star Wars
and we would I mean you know we were
just kind of like neighborhood kids we
just ride our bikes watch TV and our you
know our friends will be talking about
Star Wars and we go see that stuff and
we're just kind of like get it mrs.
monsters and stuff was where's a divorce
it did yeah and we would we would watch
tower like those movies and groups with
people and we'd be like yes Father
awesome really there's all the feelings
really what's happening and we we I
think it just it kind of happened to us
so it wasn't like we were raised by you
know NYU professors who were like oh
this is an erudite household where we
will only focus on these things we were
just dumb kids who happen to soak in
this thing that changed us and so as we
started making movies and our teens and
stuff like that we just found ourselves
matriculating and drifting towards that
sort of hard-hitting relationship stuff
and I guess the next phase that we sort
of entered was when we saw raising
arizona in a movie theater on vacation
in 1987 we it became abundantly clear to
us that a person or in this case two
people had made this movie and it it was
the first time that we could perceive
and articulate that we could actually
like perceive the personality of the
filmmaker and we didn't know what a
director was until that movie well let's
clear up that myth a little bit this is
jae's 11 I'm seven Jay's telling me all
these things and I'm seven watching you
and I'm like
yeah I'll say anything you want if you
want to hang out with me and so I just
followed J headlong into this thing and
and and rezound li worshiped him because
he would let me hang out and I got this
great education by being 7 and being led
by someone who would like show me all
these movies and we'd listen to David
Bowie I was like yeah you know and so it
wasn't till much later that this was a
true we J was really driving this train
early on